la historia del ninja gaiden en un
minuto más o menos en este juego
seguiremos a ryu hayabusa un área muy
fuerte que va a visitar a su maestro
llamado murai pero rápidamente se ven
interrumpidos pues la aldea hayabusa es
atacada por un samoré oscuro llamado
docu quien planea robar la espada de el
dragón oscuro río y todo q pelean pero
docu la parte de su mano así que arriba
se pone un nuevo traje y se pone más
mamado y decide ir en busca de docu la
paliza y para recuperarlas para robada
antes de que el mundo entre en caos
mientras ríos sigue avanzando nos damos
cuenta de que una figura misteriosa lo
observa desde lejos pero eso no nos
importa porque río sigue rompiendo
madres demoníacas y finalmente consigue
la espada del dragón oscuro pero aún no
ha acabado pues cuando un río está
escapando con la espada la figura
misteriosa se la arrebata y se revela
que todo este tiempo fue mural su
antiguo maestro quien planeó todo y usa
la espada para convertirse en un
poderoso demonio pero río logra
derrotarlo y cansado de tanto es madre
decide destruir la espada el dragón
oscuro para que no vuelva a caer en
manos equivocadas y esta es la historia
de ninja gaiden uno